We're going to get started with this session, which is titled Non-Invasive Early
Detection of Single Site Cancers.
And obviously, I just came from a presidential session on
early detection and prevention. Obviously, there's a lot of interest in this
domain, so we hope this will be an interesting session for you.
We will each be giving a talk and then probably answering questions
for our individual talks
right after our presentations, and we'll go from there.
And very lucky today to have an exemplar
group of colleagues here, Adam Yala from Berkeley, and Sandy
Markowitz from
Case Western. And
we'll be covering a full domain around pancreas
cancer. Adam will talk about what's happening in AI and imaging
across several cancer types, and then Sandy will be telling us about his work in
Barrett's. So with that, we'll go ahead and launch into the first talk.
Okay, so I'm going to talk a little bit about where we are with
pancreatic cancer, which has really been
a really tough challenge, especially in the early detection space.
Here are my disclosures.
So despite having worked on this disease for many years, and some of you in the
audience may also be working on this disease, it's
a little bit heartbreaking to see we're still at a
13% five-year survival, and that was the same rate
that we had last year. And, of course, we
know that there are new therapeutics that are now being deployed for pancreatic
cancer, and we're seeing significant results
when they're applied in the metastatic setting.
However, I think it's going to be a combination of new, more promising
effective therapeutics and down staging of pancreatic cancer that's probably going
to be the magical combination to make advances in this disease.
This is not a disease that's going away.
When I started working on it, it was thought to be a relatively uncommon cancer,
but the incidence has been increasing globally as shown by this
data. And even in the United States,
American Cancer Society facts and figures showing an increase of 1%
incidence per year since the year 2000.
We know some of the risk factors for pancreas cancer, but
I personally find when I go to clinic and see patients with pancreas cancer, only
about 50% of the patients that come in with a de novo pancreas
cancer can we clearly put our finger on with this risk factor, so we
still have some work to do here. We're going to be talking a little bit about the
genetic risk, which conservatively is associated with about
10% of pancreas cancers, but could be as high as 15% to even potentially
20% if you take into account moderate risk genes.
For the risk factors we know about, smoking, obesity, heavy alcohol
use, especially if it's associated with chronic pancreatitis,
diabetes, these are relative risk factors, but
really not more than a twofold known increase.
We do know there's a higher incidence in Blacks, and you can see the data here.
And in general, this has been thought to be a cancer that we see in older
people.
But I just want to highlight there has been a concerning
amount of data about a generational shift in cancer incidence, and this is
across about eight to 10 different cancers, but does include
pancreatic cancer.
And we're starting to see this now in the clinics where we're starting to
see patients come in who have pancreatic cancer in their 30s and 40s, where in the
past that was not very common. We don't have
complete insight into this yet, so I think there's some interesting
work that's being done around this with colon cancer, and I know Ludmil Alexandrov
is giving a plenary session at this meeting where he'll
talk about some of his microbiome work that's been pretty compelling.
But this is something we still need to delve in across all the
cancers by which we're seeing this.
And even at this point of having done a lot of work as a
field in pancreatic cancer, these kinds of films are still
not uncommon in the clinic,
where people have locally advanced cancers, where we have limited
surgical options for these patients because of extensive vascular involvement as
shown on the scan on the left, or frankly, metastatic disease, and still half
of patients when they come into the clinic have metastatic disease
at their initial presentation.
So we still do not fully
understand who is at risk for pancreas cancer, what's the level of risk,
and then, of course, what we can do about it, both in terms of early detection and
prevention. And I think this is
the important data point for us to all keep our eye on, and this
is five-year-old SEER data that if you are identified as having a Stage IA
pancreas cancer, which is two centimeters or less,
that the five-year survival rate is 83%.
So we know 83% is a very different number than 13%, and I
would like to make the case that of all the investment we should be making in
pancreas cancer right now, it's probably in early detection.
Now, how do we get
to having effective early detection, understanding risk?
It's for this reason we started an effort
called PRECEDE, and
what we're really seeing is a lot of institutional
or individual efforts around trying to understand early detection, but this is
something that really needed to have
a scale-up to tackle it in the proper way.
So we developed a collaborative research effort, which has now grown
and involves 65 academic centers around the world,
all focused on changing outcomes for pancreas cancer through early detection.
There's another 30 to 40 centers in queue that are getting their regulatory
documents in place. And we set an ambitious
goal to get for a five-year survival rate from 13% to
50% by driving early detection.
And this has grown now to be the largest effort of its kind, and
by using a novel model of data and bio
sample sharing and collaboration, we do think this will help get
us to early detection much more
quickly.This study was set up to try
to answer
and address some of the points made on this slide.
We standardized collection of clinical laboratory and imaging data, as well
as biosamples for a longitudinal study of
individuals at higher risk of pancreas cancer
worldwide. We still don't have proof that screening
saves lives. We can hypothesize it does, and small
studies would suggest that's the case, but we don't have the formal definitive
proof around this.
We need to understand not only the genetic, but also the environmental risks
associated with pancreas cancer, and this study positions us to do
so. Eighty-five percent of heritable pancreas
cancer,
which we call familial pancreas cancer, the genetic cause is unknown.
So we have the potential to address this. I'll talk about that a little bit later.
And then certainly by having this platform, any new
tool upon
which you want to say it improves our ability to detect pancreas cancer
early, this will be a platform which can be effectively
deployed.
And then, not lost on us, if we have a large enough
cohort and have a good early detection test, then we have
the opportunity to do interception and prevention
studies.
So we started this study, and it's really to
try to understand risk and early detection in
anyone who might come in the clinic who is worried about their
pancreatic cancer risk, and I'll show you who I mean by that.
We initially planned a 10,000-patient, 10-year study, but
we've already surpassed that, so now we're going to be enrolling a total of
20,000 patients.
For centers to participate, we want centers to
have some organization and
see at least 50 to 75 high-risk patients a year, have
an organized team in place, infrastructure to collect data and
samples, and agree to share data and samples to join.
Now, who do we follow in this study?
This is a really important part that I think is going to pay off in
the long term. Cohort one is the cohort that would
be typically followed at centers like yours.
These are people that will have familial pancreas cancer or have mutations
and a family member with pancreas cancer.
And this is already in the NCCN guidelines that these folks should get annual
imaging, which normally would constitute getting an MRI alternating with
an endoscopic ultrasound.
Cohort two is an interesting one. This is one we
started,
and it includes people with ATM, BRCA1 and 2 mutations,
PALB2. People who have two first-degree relatives on one
side, but perhaps not a first-degree relative, and if we have someone who
has a family history of early onset cancer.
And when we started collecting these patients and following
them, it was not in any guidelines that any of
the folks in this cohort should get longitudinal screening.
But since then, there are two guidelines that have put forth
that
some of these carriers should be screened without a family history of pancreas
cancer. ASGE suggests screening
BRCA1 and BRCA2 carriers at
age 50 without a family history. And in the NCCN now, it is
standard of care to do screening of ATM and BRCA
carriers at age 50. And that's because if you, in particular, take
ATM and BRCA2 carriers, the lifetime risk of getting pancreas cancer is
going to be about 5% to 7%. And when you're talking for a lethal
cancer, it would make sense to do screening.
Importantly, also, when we started to implement doing germline testing for
all pancreatic cancer patients in the United States, and we
found that individuals had a mutation, and we asked them, "Do
you have a history of pancreas cancer in the
family?" Over 80% of the time, the answer was no.
So that let us know that we don't want to solely rely on family
history to understand who's at risk.
Other important cohorts here
are cohort three. So these are people who should be screened, but they're
too young. So if we had a prevention approach
for individuals at high risk of pancreas cancer, this is a cohort that may come
into play. Cohort four, and this is important to know if you have a single
first-degree family member with pancreas cancer, it's now in the NCCN
guidelines that you should get germline testing.
And we currently have about 1,300 patients in cohort four in
this study.
Cohort five is just to be able to collect a biosample from a
family where we may be able to do some important research.
Cohort 6A is
the strength of the study. We predict that about 1,200
people who are in screening will get pancreas cancer
during their participation. And the good
news is, for those individuals that are in screening,
it's much more likely we're going to find an early cancer.
We've also included other cohorts which are important controls.
6B are people that have come
into the clinic with cancer that have family history
or a mutation.
Cohort 6C are early-stage pancreas cancers across our
65 centers. So if there are clinical trials upon
which we want to test therapeutics for very early-stage pancreas cancer, we
have such a cohort assembled. And then we've also added in a cyst
cohort,
and we see hundreds of thousands of patients with pancreatic cysts in the United
States every year and still don't have optimization of how
we should make decisions for
duration and frequency of screening, along with who should go to the
operating room.Now, as part of this study, we
have standardized collection of data, three-generation family history,
using pedigree templates, standardized germline testing for all
participants. We track modifiable risk
factors, diabetes, obesity, pancreatitis, smoking, alcohol use,
and we're soon adding in a list of medications, standardized
templates for imaging for both MRI and endoscopic
ultrasound, standardized collection of blood, tumor tissue when
available, and also we obtain CA 19-9
and hemoglobin AC, which may be important for model development.
We now have 11,550 patients in. We started as a
single center in May of 2020, and gradually more
sites have come on. I'll show you where the data is.
We made the investment to have Arbor Research be the data coordinating center.
They run many consortia for the NCI and other
efforts, and they help with all the regulatory documents, and also
provide a beautiful weekly report that's very
comprehensive, chronicling every patient seen at each site, in which
cohort, and all the mutational information, et cetera.
Samples are bar-coded, and then we're in the process of getting them
shipped to a central repository at five sites.
So this is the enrollment curve, and the largest enrollment is in Cohort 1,
which is
a little bit above half of the cohort.
We're almost at 5,600 patients in, in Cohort 1.
But you can see that Cohort 2, which is the second line on the right,
we have 2,300 patients. So we have a large group
of mutation carriers that we're following longitudinally,
and even the CIS cohort, we have almost 550 patients.
This is just one snapshot of the weekly data we get, and
I told you everybody gets standardized germline testing.
So you can see that we see all the mutations, and I just went A through
C, but we
have 37 standardized PGVs that are tested,
and also blood collected for genomic discovery work.
You can see here on the right that we have almost
3,000 BRCA carriers that are in study.
So you could make the case if we wanted to do an MCED study, this
might be a good place to do it because all these patients are getting annual
imaging, not only for their pancreas, but being followed
for other cancers they might be at risk.
Almost 900 ATM carriers, et cetera.
So I just would show you a little bit of the data we have for
the cancers that have been detected so far, and the numbers are still small, but we
expect that these numbers are going to increase substantially.
In fact, even since I submitted these slides, two additional cancers
have been detected in the last week.
I didn't include them, but that just shows you that with the size of this
cohort, we'll be expecting to get at least a screen-detected cancer every
week or two. So
of the 42 cases that I'm reporting on now,
six cases were found just when patients came in the door the very first time to get
imaging, and you can see
there's a spread as shown there on the right.
Interestingly, it's not just Cohort 1, which is the cohort, the
group that's typically studied at centers, but we see that we have a couple cancers
from Cohort 2.
Now, these are the screen-detected cancers so far, and
I'm glad to report that 72% of them are either high-grade
dysplasia or Stage 1. And again, also you can see
while most of them are from Cohort 1, which is the group that standardly gets
screened, that we also have some cancers from Cohort 2 and
even Cohort 4, which are the folks
that had a single family member and had germline testing and it
was negative. Now you could ask, "Well, why did they even get
followed?" Because if their germline testing was negative, you wouldn't expect them
to be screened. It was because they had an MRI
previously that showed a small cyst in their pancreas, and so that bought them the
ticket to get imaging the next year.
And in these cases, we found a small cancer that was not in the cyst.
So that's just an important point for us to pay attention to, because it
might be that there's a subset of patients with a single
family member that we may be able to develop criteria that would
warrant longitudinal screening.
Just wanted to show you this.
In Cohort 1, again, we found there were three high-grade
dysplasia, not even
invasive cancer yet, 73% early stage.
About half were gene mutation carriers, and about half were
FPC. In Cohort 2, these are people
without a family history
that had mutations. Four of them were BRCA2, and as I told you in
the NCCN guidelines, there is recommendation for screening for
BRCA2. But three of them were BRCA1,
and so that highlights the fact as we accumulate this data that we may be
able to bend the NCCN guidelines to help provide guidance who with
BRCA1 should get pancreas screening.
And then you can see we had three cancers in Cohort 4.
So this is something for us to be paying attention to as this data
evolves.
And again, if you just look at the distribution of early-stage
cancers in the study so far versus SEER
cohort
data, which shows
traditionally about 11% of pancreas cancers
are found early otherwise.
Now, an important part of really moving the needle
is
trying to understand any screen-detected cancer that's not a Stage
1,
what might be the reason? And so we now have established a monthly
PRESEED worldwide tumor board, and we
examine every single case, and we're setting up to get independent
imaging review. And so the question is: Was it a
case in which the
time interval between screening was delayed?Was the
imaging suboptimal?
Was there something subtle on a prior scan that now that we look back
in retrospect was there?
Or are there a subset of pancreas cancers that may be
genomically more aggressive and that'll be important for us
to know about as we
think about being more precise in our screening strategies.
And I just want to talk about that point on this slide.
So there's been a lot of work trying to understand the genomic trajectories
of pancreas cancer, and there was a paper published in
"Nature" in 2010 that put forth using mathematical
modeling that there was a very slow ramp-up on the
trajectory to pancreas cancer, where there was a gradual accumulation of
mutations, and you can see that up there on the top right.
However, there was initial hypothesis
generating paper by Paco Real, published in "Gastroenterology" in
2003, and subsequent work by Fayez Nota that said,
while there may be
cancers that have this gradual
accumulation mutations, we do know that some
pancreatic cancers actually undergo chromothripsis and
have a punctuated equilibrium where they may have loss of multiple
tumor suppressor genes at the same time.
And so that trajectory may be different.
And so we may find that there's a subset of patients at risk for pancreas cancer
that have that kind of trajectory, and that'll be really important
for us to know. And they may be people that we have to screen at a different
cadence or using different tools.
Now when you have a platform like this, the goal is not to necessarily just have
the platform, but to have a platform upon which now
we have the size and scale of data to answer questions.
These are all active projects going on.
Long-read sequencing in PDAC, I'll show you a slide on that.
Early detection biomarkers, AI-enabled image analysis
and multimodal data, polygenic risk scores, et cetera.
So now we have
dozens and dozens of scientists around the world that are able to tackle
these unresolved questions using this platform and data
set.
I want to give a shout-out for this collaboration, which is to do
a pilot of 200 pancreas cancer patients that have familial
cancer with a negative germline panel.
We're in partnership with Ambry Genetics and PacBio.
We're doing long-read sequencing, and we have some interesting
hits, which maybe we'll be able to present once they're validated in an upcoming
meeting.
And then PRECEDE is a good platform if there's a
biomarker test that has high performance where we can test it
longitudinally to predict its sensitivity and
specificity in a
target population. So there are now two active studies, one with
a test called Advantech, and soon to come on board,
PancraSure, and these both have high performance in comparing
stage one pancreas cancer to both normals and
benign disease controls. And so we're going to see how they perform
longitudinally over time.
So in summary,
this has been an exciting project and
platform that is being performed at large scale to
really try to change survival for pancreas cancer by driving
early detection. Importantly, we have
engagement of key stakeholders all listed here
that all have skin in the game to
allow us to elicit change, and the biggest advocates of this study
are patients.
With no marketing communication budget, we have patients coming
forward all around the world to participate in this study because they think by
everybody working together and sharing data, it's going to make an impact.
And just a slide acknowledging all the investigators,
funders, and
the hope that we can use this platform to really transform early
detection. Thank you.
So I think we
have five minutes for questions. If anyone has a question, I'm happy to answer it.
Yeah.
I have a question. Thank you for that lovely talk.
I send all my patients to PRECEDE, so all good.
Once you get into the pancreatic cyst
area,
I start thinking about PNETs as well.
And so there are clearly inherited syndromes such as VHL with multiple
pancreatic cysts, and that's a PNET thing where the screening is very
different. So I'm just curious how you're thinking
about that in the context of PRECEDE, where those patients have
historically not, for example-
Yeah
... had US.
So, I think it's a fascinating point.
The first paper we published from PRECEDE, looking at the
first 1,800 patients in, we found 12 incidental
PNETs. So that did raise--
We did pay attention to that because we did wonder if perhaps there's a field
defect where we might see more PNETs in this setting.
We are doing a separate study, and actually that's in partnership with Adam.
We're in the UC system. We're going back 10 years,
to look at who got pancreas cancer and who got
a PNET and see if we can develop multimodal data integration
to develop predictive algorithms.
So I think there are ways we can leverage this to go a little bit deeper in the
PNET space, and we can talk more about that.
But I think it's a really good point.
Yeah.
Hi, Diane. Yue Feng from Johns Hopkins.
SoThank you for your tremendous effort on this to
build out this platform. So I have two questions.
Actually, first one is whether the cyst fluid will be considered to you or
like a cyst?
Yeah.
We do have a U01
that is comparing
some of these promising early detection blood tests
with
cyst fluid genetic analysis, and in this particular project, it's
PANCREAseek versus gold standard, which is path, surgical
path in patients who undergo surgical resection for cysts.
In the U01, that's cohort one. Cohort two are people with larger
cysts, 2.5 centimeters or greater, or main pancreatic duct six
millimeters
or greater, in which we will follow them for five years, and we expect about a
third of those patients will go to the operating room, and so we'll have some
longitudinal data comparing performance of blood tests,
cyst fluid analysis, and of course, path.
Okay.
Yeah.
And my second question is actually, you show two new
technology. One is on the methylation, the other is based on the protein
immunoassay.
Yeah.
Is there other technology can be considered to
contribute, for example, like a mass spec based assay for the
protein, glycoprotein, something like that?
Yeah. Thanks for the question. So as you all know, there are many different tools
in the toolbox to look at blood samples or
even urine samples, et cetera, biosamples for early
detection.
We're receptive to using other tools since we're having
comprehensive longitudinal biosample collection on
these patients. If
a group has something that looks promising, but they don't
have
enough data, then we try to help that group use
retrospective convenient samples to help build their
data set. But we do want to have a fairly high bar if we're going to test
something longitudinally because we're cognizant that those are samples
that are important and precious, and so we
just want to be thoughtful for their use. Yep.
Thank you.
And probably time for one more. Yep.
So I'll make it quick.
So I'm curious because this data set is so large and there's enrichment in these
carriers, do you collect information about previous
cancer histories? Maybe some of these patients have breast or prostate in the BRCA1
or BRCA2 at least.
We do, yeah. So I think that's why this is a very
important study. And of course,
depending on the timeframe that someone with a mutation comes to see us, they
may have already
had their
breast cancer or ovarian cancer or prostate cancer being dealt with.
But we do track, not only pancreas cancers, but other cancers that
any of the carriers develop as part of the whole project. Yep.
I see. So if someone develops a breast cancer, you'll record that, and
you will continue following them up
longitudinally for pancreatic cancer?
We do, yeah. Because what we found is a lot of people,
for example, with a BRCA2 mutation, they didn't really
realize that they were at risk for pancreas cancer, and so that's
about increasing awareness. So often, we might not see
somebody until after they've already seen an oncologist with a new
diagnosis of a breast cancer, and then they'll get referred to us.
"Oh, it's really important you get followed for pancreas cancer, too." So.
Thank you.
All right, thanks. And we're going to go ahead and move on
to our next speaker. So Sandy Markowitz is going to come and talk to
us. Let me get your slides up here, Sandy.
About Barrett's.
Thanks, Diane.
Well, let me begin by thanking
Diane and the organizing committee for the pleasure of being able to
speak to you today. I'm Sandy Markowitz.
I'm going to speak about biomarker-based early detection of Barrett's
esophagus and its cancer progression, a work that our team
in Cleveland has been engaged in for some years now.
More succinctly, I'm going to talk about biomarker-based interception of
esophageal adenocarcinoma.
These are my disclosures.
And this is the challenge of esophageal adenocarcinoma,
or EAC.
It's been the fastest growing solid tumor in the United States
over the last several decades. It has a five-year
survival of less than 20%, a death toll that now
exceeds that of ovarian cancer, and it is seldom, seldom
detected early.
Now, the opportunity to intercept this disease lies in the
fact that it has an obligate precursor, which is known
as Barrett's esophagus. And here on
the slide, you can see the transition from the normal squamous
histology of the esophagus to this columnar
histology that marks the Barrett's condition and that gives
rise to the esophageal adenocarcinomas.
Now, Barrett's is thought to be initiated by esophageal injury,
most commonly longstanding gastroesophageal reflux disease
or GERD.
And the Barrett's itself has a progression phase to
Barrett's with dysplasia, which are the immediate precursors of the cancers.
Now, the importance of this process is that if these
dysplasias are detected, they can be ablated through
endoscopic technologies, thereby intercepting and preventing the
cancer.The
other important thing about Barrett's is that it arises in a
stereotypical location in the distal esophagus, right near the
gastroesophageal junction.
Okay? Now, because of the burden of this disease,
the American College of Gastroenterology has recommended Barrett's
screening for all men with chronic GERD and
two additional risk factors from the list that's shown.
However,
endoscopic screening for Barrett's has been a massive failure in
acceptance, both by patients and by physicians.
And the result is that 95% of the time when an esophageal
adenocarcinoma is diagnosed, there was never any screening
to detect the antecedent Barrett's condition.
So to attempt to do something about this, our
group decided to look for biomarkers that could
be present in Barrett's and esophageal cancers.
And we initially focused on methylated DNAs.
We did a genome-wide screen for differentially methylated loci
that were diagnostic of Barrett's or esophageal adenocarcinomas,
in part using reduced representation bisulfite sequencing
from biopsies of these conditions.
Now, that biopsy-based screen nominated two
differentially methylated loci.
The first of these was methylated vimentin.
Now, this was a locus we had previously discovered as
a wonderful biomarker of colon carcinomas, and
indeed, we had brought this forward in collaboration with Exact
Sciences as the Cologuard test, and it was the first methylated
DNA stool test for early detection of colon cancer.
We found it was even more commonly present in the Barrett's than it was in the
colon. The second biomarker was methylated
CCNA1 that came out of the reduced representation
bisulfite screen. So to validate these biomarkers,
we took advantage of a cohort of nearly 300 individuals
who had had endoscopically guided cytology brushings, and we
analyzed the DNA off of those cytology brushings and found that both
methylated vimentin and methylated CCNA1 could
distinguish the normal esophagus from the Barrett's esophagus with an
AUC of over 0.95 for both of these markers
individually.
So that got us biomarkers. Of course, we still needed to find a way
to get rid of the endoscope.
And to do that, we developed a swallowable
textured balloon,
shown here in cartoon form, with the idea that it could be pulled back
through the gastroesophageal junction to get what would effectively be a
Pap smear of the distal esophagus.
Now, this is what the device actually looks like.
And here is the balloon tip, which is the functional part of the
device. And if we hone in on it, what you can see
is that the tip of the device is actually a capsule about the size of a
vitamin pill. Here's the close-up.
And in the stomach, one can insert air through this silicon
catheter that's attached and pop out the textured balloon to
get the best sample. Now importantly, once you have the
sample, you can then withdraw the air and pop the balloon back
inside the capsule, and this now traps the sample and
protects it from dilution and contamination as you pull
this back through the esophagus and the oropharynx.
So here's how it looks from the patient point of view.
The patient swallows the capsule.
In the stomach, the air is inserted, and the balloon is deployed.
You pull it back to get the Pap smear.
You take the air out to invert the balloon and trap the sample.
And then once it's out of the patient through the mouth, you can cut off the
balloon and send it to the lab.
So we combined the biomarker panel and the balloon
and did an initial pilot trial of this technology, finding
that we had 90% sensitivity for detecting
non-dysplastic early-stage Barrett's esophagus, and that was
at a 92% specificity.
Now, since our initial "Science Translational Medicine" publication,
there are now four clinical trials of this technology.
Across these four cohorts, the sensitivity for detecting
Barrett's has ranged between 80% and 90%.
The sensitivity for detecting
cancer has basically been 100%,
with one anomalous case missed.
And the specificity of the approach has also ranged
between 80% and 90%.
Of a clinical value, the positive predictive value of the
technology is over 30%, and the negative predictive
value is nearly 99%.
So at this point, the status of the technology is that it has a
name. The balloon is called EsaCheck.
The methylated DNA panel is called EsaGuard.
The EsaCheck device has been awarded 510approval from the
FDA. The EsaGuard test panel has been awarded FDA
breakthrough device designation.
And the EsaCheck and EsaGuard test combination were
included in the 2022 American College of Gastroenterology
updated Barrett's clinical guidelines.
The technology has now been successfully commercialized, and
a Medicare CMS review is pending for insurance
coverage.
So what's next?
Well, first of all, 40% of esophageal
adenocarcinomas arise in individuals who never report
having reflux
symptoms.So how do
we address this population of individuals?
So we tried to develop a pilot study to use the
EASE チ ェ ッ ク ESAGR technology to screen asymptomatic but
high-risk individuals. Now, we defined high risk as
any individual with three risk factors for having Barrett's,
and that basically comes down to white men over 50,
Caucasian males over 50.
We've done an initial pilot study of 120 of these high-risk
individuals. Thirty-four of them were test positive for the
methylation markers. Twenty-seven of those individuals have come to
endoscopy now, and nine of them had Barrett's, giving us a positive
predictive value in this population of 33%.
Basically exactly the same positive predictive value as we got in a
symptomatic GERD population and bringing promise
that this approach could be used.
Let's see. There we go. Eighty-six individuals were test
negative, and 22 of those have come to endoscopy, and all
of them were negative for Barrett's, giving us right now a negative predictive
value of 100% in this asymptomatic population.
Moving forward, we now have a clinical trial, a validation trial
underway. I'm supported by an NIH Division of Cancer
Prevention R01, with the aim of accruing 800 of these
asymptomatic high-risk subjects to validate this screening approach.
Here is the team that has been driving this technology forward,
Amitab Chak and Joe Willis, with whom I developed the device,
Helen Wanova, who developed the biomarker panel in our
laboratory, and particularly Amitab Chak, who's led all of the clinical
trials of this technology in collaboration with his clinical
collaborators in the BetterNet consortium.
However, identifying individuals with Barrett's is only the first step,
because in order to intercept the cancers, we have to
identify when the Barrett's progresses to dysplasia and then send these
patients to ablation. And the challenge of this
is indicated on this survival plot from the
AGCC staging criteria for esophageal
adenocarcinoma. And what you'll note is that even stage
one, early stage one esophageal
adenocarcinomas have
over 20% 10-year mortality rate. So
you really have to catch this disease at the stage of
high-grade dysplasia
or early intramucosal cancers, because once the disease is
submucosal, even if it's stage one, there's a good chance these patients will
succumb.
So the standard approach has been
triennial surveillance endoscopies and random
biopsies. And the problem with that approach is that these small
progressed clones of cancer and dysplasia are often missed by
random biopsy sampling.
Moreover, the esophageal adenocarcinomas can develop quickly,
and they often present clinically in between these three-year
interval surveillance exams. And even when they're caught
under surveillance, 40% of these cancers are already
metastatic.
So we clearly need more sensitive methods than just random
biopsies to detect high-risk progression during
surveillance of Barrett's patients.
So the molecular challenge here is finding a small progressed
dysplastic Barrett's clone in a much larger
non-dysplastic Barrett's segment.
So this is the classic needle in the haystack problem.
And this problem is amplified by the fact that blood doesn't help.
And that's because these small clones of
dysplastic Barrett's or of early stage one
esophageal adenocarcinomas do not put enough
ctDNA into the blood to be
detected by any of the current ctDNA-based tests.
However,
the breakthrough was
when
our group, together with Bert Vogelstein's group, realized that we
could take the technology that the Vogelstein lab had
developed to detect ctDNA
abnormalities in blood and instead apply it to a Barrett's
brushing sample. All right.
So the idea was to take a brushing of the esophagus of the
patient with Barrett's,
amplify that DNA on the brush with a
PCR-based technology that would look at 350,000
amplicons, sequence the amplicons, and then use
read imbalances, too many reads or too few reads,
as indicators of chromosomal gains or losses.
Okay. And then we interrogated this panel of chromosomal
gains or losses with an algorithm that we called Barrett's
Aneuploidy Detection, or BAD. Okay.
So let me show you.
So the first question was, well, can you just use aneuploidy to detect Barrett's
progression? And it is indeed true that high-grade
dysplasias are highly aneuploid, as you see on this violin
plot.
The problem is that a third of non-dysplastic Barrett's are aneuploid
as well. So aneuploidy alone is not a useful
biomarker.
Whoops.
What happened there?
Let's try this guy.
Okay.So
the breakthrough came from realizing that esophageal
adenocarcinomas were typified by a stereotypical
set of chromosomal gains or losses, as shown in this panel.
And moreover, all the variability of this panel of gains or
losses could be captured in just six of these
chromosomal alterations, the ones that are shown in red.
So here's a list of these six indicator chromosomal
changes. And those of you who are cancer geneticists will
immediately recognize that this maps very nicely into
CDKN2A, P53,
KRAS.
And so these chromosomal gains and losses that we pulled
out because they captured the variability of the panel, actually are
driver events in the development of this malignancy.
So here was the algorithm. We would take the BAD
score, and we would ask, "Does a particular patient's lesion
show aneuploidy?" And if it didn't, we set it aside.
We called it Not Bad.
If it did show aneuploidy, we then went further and asked,
"Does the aneuploidy include gains or losses on our
driver chromosome panel?" If it didn't, we again set the
lesion aside. Initially, we called it Maybe Bad.
But if a lesion showed both aneuploidy and a hit on a driver
chromosome, we called it Very Bad.
So here is a heat map,
showing
in this column,
lesions that are aneuploid. And here you can see all these
non-dysplastic Barrett's lesions that are aneuploid.
And here's the heat map of this validation cohort of patients.
And now you can see essentially all the lesions that were
aneuploid and that were cancers or high-grade dysplasias
are recognized as Very Bad, but only a very, very small number
of the non-dysplastic Barrett's are called Very Bad.
So this is the biomarker we were looking for,
and the performance is shown here.
We detected 96% of the cancers as Very Bad,
68% of the high-grade dysplasias as Very Bad, and
only 7% of the non-dysplastic Barrett's lesions.
So the immediate question is, can now this molecular biomarker
of Very Bad be used to supplement or replace random
biopsies in order to improve Barrett's surveillance?
There's another question,
and that was posed by the fact that we had 36
months of surveillance on this cohort.
And over 36 months, two of those non-dysplastic
Barrett's that we called Very Bad progressed, one to high-grade
dysplasia, one to a cancer. In contrast, none of the Not
or Maybe Bad lesions progressed, and that gave us a
nominal P value of 0.004 for BAD being able to
predict non-dysplastic lesions that would progress.
So where we're going with the BAD technology
is right now in collaboration with the Early Detection Research
Network of the NIH and with the Servent Clinical Consortium.
We're following a cohort of 365 patients with
low-grade dysplasia to ask whether BAD will correctly predict the
ones that are going to progress.
Additionally,
in work funded by the Division of Cancer Prevention RO1,
we're accruing a cohort of 1,300 patients with
non-dysplastic Barrett's who will similarly be followed to see if
BAD can detect initial
progression that's missed by random biopsies and also
predict that progression.
Now, here is the BAD team. As I mentioned, the idea
was originally conceived in a discussion between Bert Vogelstein and
me on a visit to Baltimore.
The work has been carried forward, the molecular work by Chris
Duvel, who developed the REALSEEK technology that we're using for the
PCR
and chromosomal gains or losses. The clinical trials are
being led by Amitabh Chawla at Case, and Helen Wanova in my lab
is also contributing to the molecular work.
And then we have a group of key further collaborators,
Nick Papadopoulos, Jitan Badiga, Ken Kinzler in the
Vogelstein lab, and Joe Willis in Cleveland.
However, even if you can identify the high-grade
dysplasias in the Barrett's and ablate it, the work is not yet
done.
And that's because after ablation, there's an 8% annual
recurrence rate in these patients.
So we wondered, could we use our methylated DNA as a
marker of minimal residual disease after ablation to
identify the patients who are going to be at high risk for disease recurrence?
We were able to take advantage of Nick Shahin's
biorepository at UNC,
to look at 80 individuals who had had cancer or high-grade
dysplasia that were ablated, and that after the ablation,
had a biopsy taken, a single biopsy taken of the
healed neosquamous epithelium.
Twenty-seven of those patients have already recurred, and when we tested
their biopsies for methylated DNA, 13 of those
27 individuals had detectable methylated CCNA1 in
their biopsy.
In contrast, if we looked at the 53 patients who have not recurred
and remain without evidence of disease, only one of those
biopsies showed a detectable methylated
CCNA1.And if you quickly do the arithmetic,
the relative risk for disease recurrence associated
with
continued positivity for DNA methylation is a relative risk
of 25. So this is an enormously predictive biomarker,
and we are now carrying this forward in a prospective clinical trial that's
underway using esophageal brushings to more
comprehensively survey the post-ablated esophagus,
not just a single biopsy.
And this is also being supported by the NIH Early Detection Research
Network. Whoops.
Here's the minimal residual disease team that's been doing
this work. First, Nick Shaheen at UNC, who provided all the
clinical samples for this study, and then our team at Case,
my lab, Amitop Chak and Joe Willis.
And let us also acknowledge Suman Verma and the Lucid
Diagnostics clinical lab team who've been running the assays.
So, in conclusion,
non-endoscopic DNA biomarker-based screening for Barrett's disease
is a new and now clinically available technology captured
in EsaCheck and EsaGuard.
Second, molecular surveillance for early detection of Barrett's
progression to high-grade dysplasia and/or cancer has proof
of principle in the work around BAD.
And third, molecular predictors of patients at high risk for
Barrett's progression, that is very BAD non-dysplastic Barrett's,
or for post-ablation disease recurrence because of markers
of minimal residual disease, are both now being tested in
ongoing prospective clinical trials.
So, with that, let me thank all of you for your kind attention
in
coming to this session today, and I'm happy to take any questions.
Must've been a bad talk.
Any questions from the panel?
How many markers do you need?
Just two.
Just two?
Yes.
So there's different approaches to this.
Of course, the world is much seized by big data and AI analysis of
it. But the price you pay every time you add a marker
is you reduce specificity.
Right? And specificity is the main driver of positive
predictive value, and it's positive predictive value that a
clinician cares about the most.
If I do this test and get a positive result, what's the likelihood
the patient has the disease?
Okay. So our focus was on developing a panel
that would have the smallest number of high-performing markers
to bring forward.
I have a question.
Hi, Sandy. Jim Willey at the University of Toledo.
Can you see me?
Yeah. So,
in your sequencing analyses, did you identify any
nucleotide driver mutations at the single nucleotide
level? Was it only the chromosome copy number
changes that were associated with the BAD
situation?
So
this technology that was
developed by Chris Duvel in Bert's lab and called REAL seeks,
is really quite outlike, and it uses just a single primer pair,
and the single primer pair works because it's directed toward
Alu sequences,
or line sequences. So you can use a single primer pair.
What you're picking up are, by and large, non-coding sequences.
I'm trying to see you because the light's in my eye.
But you're picking up repetitive DNA
sequences. So these are not super useful for
looking for SNVs, but they're extremely useful.
They have enough sequence identity that you can map them back
to the genome, and they're highly useful for scoring
gains and losses of chromosomal arms.
Do you see any advantage to doing the additional analysis to look
for low variant allele
copy?
So the question of whether you could do this with
whole genome sequencing and
with
low coverage whole genome DNA sequencing to map gains and losses is
a good one. We haven't done that comparative
experiment.
Okay. All right.
But-
Well, thank you. It's wonderful work as it is, so thank you.
It was a great presentation.
Thanks, Jim.
I see somebody coming to the...
Great talk. A really quick one. Bruno from France, Institut
Curie.
Just step forward to the mic a little bit.
It's better now.
Yeah.
There you go. So have you tried to benchmark this data with the
cytosponge-
Sorry, I'm having a little trouble hearing. Can you speak a little louder?
Sure. Did you benchmark this data with the cytosponge from the group
in the UK?
Can we benchmark...
Yeah, the data from your balloon with the people who are doing the
cytosponge in the UK,
cytology from the esophageal
tissue as well.
I'm sorry, I think you're asking me about Rebecca's work from the UK.
Yeah. Exactly.
But I'm having trouble hearing. You want to come forward and just...
He was asking if you could benchmark
Oh, if could I benchmark or compare?
We do not have head-to-head data to benchmark it
compared to Cyto Sponge.
But what
I can say from the non-head-to-head comparison is that
the advantage of the balloon technology is that we have
exquisite sensitivity for short segment Barrett's, which Cyto
Sponge in the non-head-to-head comparisons,
Cyto Sponge misses, and that's what you would expect
when you are using a technology like Cyto Sponge
where you pull the sponge back along the entire length of the esophagus,
okay, and dilute the sample. The advantage of the balloon is
that we can focus it to sample just the distal esophagus,
and then capture the sample inside the balloon so that we
don't dilute it as we bring it further up through the
esophagus. So we detect short segment
Barrett's with exactly the same sensitivity and
specificity as we do long segment Barrett's, whereas in
all of the studies of Cyto Sponge, short segment Barrett's has
basically been censored from the analysis.
Thanks.
I hope that addressed your question.
All
right.
Thanks for that great talk, Sandy.
And now we'll go ahead and move on to our last speaker,
Dr. Adam Yala from Berkeley, who will be
talking to us about AI and precision imaging. Adam?
Thanks for translating the English accent.
Everyone, it's a pleasure to share my work with you.
I don't usually wear a hat during talks.
I'm trying not to go blind while speaking to you, but I swear that...
I'll move a little bit closer.
I'm excited to share our work on AI for personalized cancer care.
So by, these are my disclosures. I started a company where I'm CEO, and I've done a
lot of consulting.
I'm a computer scientist by training, and I think a lot about cancer as a
computational problem. And my general lens is there's just simply a huge amount
of data that we often don't use to drive what's the right decision at the right
time. So individual patients, say pictorial here in the world of breast,
has many gigabytes of data. In the world of tokens, in the
modern AI landscape, that's hundreds of billions of tokens.
And there's a question of, well, how do I actually integrate all of that to make
something better?
And the talk today and my work
spans across many parts of that arc.
One, the problem of prediction. How do I use all the data I have available to go
beyond the
high-risk checklist that we see recurring across all of medicine?
How do we better understand what the patient has today and their progression of the
future as an AI problem first order of principles?
Given that, how do we make new kinds of guidelines and algorithms as a control
problem, the way we think about learning navigation or robotics, but
apply it to health? And finally, even if you have those things, it's not enough.
You have to prove that it works. And the models will always change, so how do we
invent an era of trials that are actually compatible with
continually changing models? So that's the point for today.
I'm going to speed run through all of them.
And
let's dive in. So a motivating example I've used a lot throughout my career is the
world of breast cancer screening, where by and large, like many other regimes tell
people, "Do the same thing. You're a person above 40.
Show up every year." And with every type of program that exists, there's always
kind of two edges of the spectrum. On one side, this program
as is, is not quite sensitive enough, and there are some people who will still get
interval cancer as worse outcomes. If you knew, you'd want to have done more.
There's more sensitive screening options out there.
And for a bunch of people who will never get cancer, the program itself is
associated with a lot of anxiety and harm, and you wish you would've actually
either made the process better or have done less, and it's hard to have both at the
same time.
And the solution is in back of my lens of prediction and control is kind of
simple. Predict and ascend who's going to have it, turn the statement of only if we
knew into a statement of foresight, and then given that, act, right?
There should be guidelines that are personalized by the individual and inherently
dynamic as life progresses over time.
So that is not a new idea. There's been a lot of risk models.
We've already seen the session today.
We already have risk models for breast that have been adopted for
decades that have the following shape.
There's age, there's family history, maybe we elevate some because of the genetic
marker we know about. The trouble with these markers is that, like in
many other regimes, they're not so powerful that they explain
the full phenomenon. So in the world of breast, up until actually very
recently, the guidelines changed this year.
The mainstream guideline of who is high risk of breast cancer
only flags a quarter of all the people who are going to get breast cancer in the
next five years. So it's not very sensitive as a risk model.
The sensitivity is only 25%, and it's also not very specific.
The vast majority of people who are called high risk will not get cancer within a
six-year observation period.
So stepping back to my central frame as a computer scientist, my North Star is,
well, how do I use literally everything I know to do better?
And I will start off with some of my older work showing steps towards
that direction. Now, there's a bunch of papers here that kind of
big picture as well. There's a lot more than we know than those questions within
that questionnaire. We have pixels. We have morphological data. We have phenotypes.
Let's do something with that directly.
Now, one of these models is called Mirai, which is some work for my PhD.
And I won't belabor the technical details.
They feel artisanal in the modern AI era.
But the core point I want to highlight is that it's with actually less information
than we normally use within our clinical calculators.
We can not only get a much better result, but it works very reliably, and it's a
very repeatable playbook. So I mean by that, the blue bar here is a Tyrer-Cuzick.
It's pages of questionnaires. It has breast density.
It has... more things you would normally want to
track. Image alone beats that by a large margin.
This here is five-year AUCs. But out of the box, it works across many hospitals,
across many places.
And that's not a uniquely breast cancer story.
We have very similar models in lung cancer, looking at, once again, the blue bar is
another questionnaire focused on smoking history, the best clinical knowledge of
that domain. Single CT does much better.
And together, these two models, this slide is out of date, but it's like 90
hospitals, 30 countries have independently tested it, so things work.
Now, it's one thing to have better AUCs.
A very healthy question is, so what?
So I want to bring it back to the central motivation, and there's two types of
trials we're running
on the two sides of the spectrum. So one is, well, to have a better risk model,
and I say that the current screening regime still leaves things to be desired
because we want to be able to escalate if we know something.
Well,
we should try exactly that. So we have an ongoing multi-site clinical trial
supported by BCRF, where we're looking at high-risk patients.
A lot of them get supplemental screening MRI
after the negative mammogram to catch would otherwise be a later stage cancer
sooner. So that study's ongoing. If folks are interested, that's the NCTID.
A pleasant surprise to me, actually, NCCN updated this
year
to officially support image-based risk models.
The individual threshold here leaves some things to be desired, but this world
of
we have better notions of prediction.
We understand the future better, so we can better drive allocations is
finally getting broader and broader accepted.
It feels like shouting till the wind works eventually.
So that's the picture of how do we use this foresight to make care
better at the top of the spectrum. But we also mentioned there's a bunch of
people who won't have cancer, and their association with the process is
generally not great and causes a lot of anxiety.
So that's the focus of another trial we recently ran.
Here the focus had been just on the actual flow of the screening pipeline.
So at SFGH, our kind of safety net hospital in SF,
the median time to go from you get a screening mammogram to know that you have
cancer or know that you don't have it after a diagnostic resolution is like 40 plus
days.
It's not a fun process.
But we have access to a risk score, which is closely linked to diagnosis
in real time. So in this study, we basically showed by plugging in Mirai the right
way, we could bring down that time for, say,
cancer is down from 57 days median time to knowing the diagnostic resolution
down to 12 hours. And that is now becoming part of standard of
care at SFGH pending some PACS integrations.
So both of these
individual settings, both the Mirai MRI trial, Mirai SDA trial to me are
base cases of very simple things you can do if you have notions of better
foresight, and you can expect a better foresight as an AI problem.
Now, I won't get into this today, but there's actually much bigger opportunities.
The way you even think about guideline design as a reinforcement learning problem.
We don't say, well, if I give you an MRI once, I saw something.
Should you stay in the MRI forever? Probably not, right?
You know something should be able to dynamically escalate and deescalate if at all
in context. We have some work on that area.
I won't get into it today, but if folks are interested, the reference is
screenshotted. Okay, so
the most exciting thing to me about this world of prediction is that it has a
fundamentally different shape than the types of models we've used in the past.
If I have an individual biomarker, or I have a notion of
BRCA. A BRCA is not going to get meaningfully transformed as a definition year over
year. That is not true of the models that look at phenotypes directly.
So I want to talk briefly about the existing/ongoing foundation model
boom in this space and why I'm excited to say it will continue to
get dramatically better very quickly.
So for that, I want to talk about our work building a foundation model called
Pillar Zero. And first I want to say, what is a foundation model?
What are the goals you would hope to have for a model of this kind?
Well, if we're actually making things better, we're kind of used to this in the
world of language. We're used to GPT-5 should be better than four.
Well, for a vision model to be real, it should be helpful in everything, like many
hundreds of things that you work on.
So it should be broadly available to the community.
If you have something that humans can't do, say like estimate future lung cancer
risk or future pancreatic cancer risk, it should be better at that.
So it should push beyond the regime of what is already known,
and it should work requiring a lot less data than before.
So if before I needed 20,000 samples to solve a problem, maybe I only need 1,000 or
500.
And finally, if all those things are true, you have a real foundation model, and
practically, this moment has not really happened in the community yet.
The models I showed you for lung cancer pre-trained on YouTube.
So reliable, the way to actually leverage the massive amount of data we have as
health systems to actually make everything better has been elusive.
Now,
to motivate what I'm going to show you, I first want to talk briefly about
evaluation.
Foundation models in radiology is not a hot idea.
People thought about this since at least 2017.
The problem with a lot of our evaluations to date and what you'll see in the
frontier evals of Gemini and OpenAI Anthropic, is they use stuff like this,
where you take 2D screenshots off of a website and say, "Is there a liver in this
image?" Which I will argue is broadly useless.
And so this type of eval has held back the community.
And so everything I'm going to show is going to have a different type of setup, in
which for any individual exam, the input to the test I'm going to show you is going
to be a full volume unadulterated in DICOM.
The ask is a long list of findings that attending radiologists
curate. So it's not like, is there a liver? Is there pancreatic cancer?
Is there pneumatitis? Can we actually find in the image things you would expect to
see from a radiology report?
And this is the flavor of the evaluation I'm about to show you for the hundreds of
conditions that we already do and know off of the imaging.
Okay, so
now that we talked about evaluation, I can actually substitute these claims.
Let's start off with, do we outperform baselines across hundreds of findings?
And the answer is yes. So Pillar Zero is a
new type of model. It uses something called an Atlas Backbone.
There's new architectural innovations I won't get into.
But across hundreds of types of conditions, the average ACC will range
from
82 to 90, and it's much better we can get out of the Google, Microsoft models, and
models from Alibaba like Qwen, and the recent vision model from
Stanford.On the right-hand side, I'm showing you just absolute top win rates are
like broadly, no matter what you're working on, it should be able to
be helpful. So I'll put a check on that.
The pre-training for this is a vision language model.
So it uses a lot of radiology reports as part of our pre-training.
And radiology reports don't talk about who's going to get cancer in the
future. So a critical thing is, well, does it do things that humans don't do?
So I showed you before that we have this like cybil model, which does lung cancer.
Well, pre-training on Pillar makes that model better, and it doesn't just make
it better on the original test set, which is endless, but also works better in
external validation in Taiwan and MGH.
And this is not on the slides here, but we have some colleagues that just tried
this on ILD, like interstitial lung disease.
I might be pronouncing that wrong.
Their traditional approaches give them ACs of 80.
They pre-train on Pillar zero, they get 95.
So in like every condition we've tried it,
it can boost the thing that you want.
So the next thing is, well, do you need less data?
I mentioned in building the original type of model, pre-trained on YouTube.
And why did I pre-train it on YouTube? Because it's the best thing that I had.
Here, I'm showing you some experiments.
We're trying to build a hemorrhage detector. Do you need less data than before?
So in the purple lines I'm showing you here was medical specific pre-trained
models. So things like Merlin, things pre-trained on other CTs.
These gray lines are not trained on that at all.
So this gray line, I'll see if I can use the mouse here, is
pre-training on YouTube. And it's
basically equivalent to this like CT model, Merlin.
We show that our pre-training lets you get to 95 AC with using one twentieth of the
data. And this kind of core property of you need less to achieve something
is actually achieved. And something to me is very exciting about these models is
that they enable new things.
So
why build foundation models? One, I mean, I want better numbers across every task
that I work on because those better numbers should enable better clinical
workflows.
But as the models get better, they open up a bigger playground of tasks that
otherwise could not solve. You notice that the older work I showed you focused on
breast and lung, some
diseases with a huge amount of volume.
So you can actually build things with hundreds of thousands of scans and many
thousands of cancers. That locks you off from working in many other and really
important problems like pancreatic cancer.
So by making things more sample efficient and kind of changing the line of what is
now AI bold versus classical radiomics, it opens up a bigger
field. And that's something I'm super excited about.
And what I've showed you so far is pillar zero.
Pillar one is going to be much better.
And as it's getting much cheaper now to build models across these new questions,
say, questions that are otherwise kind of locked out, things in treatments we
usually rely on much more radiomics-style approaches,
and pancreas cancer, then efforts like PRECI to allow you to have
large-scale prospective data collection across many places at the same time, yet
ever more important, because that's going to become the true bottleneck to making
these things actually hit real impact. So I'm very excited to partner in that work.
Okay, so I've talked a lot about prediction.
The technology is still rapidly improving, and I'll say that for a couple of
reasons. One, pillar zero to me is like a...
I mean, it's useful and I encourage people, it's free and it's open and encourage
people to use it if they're doing this kind of work.
But that only used like hundreds of thousands of imaging exams or like a single
AMC.
Pillar one is a commercial style model that is
as of now looking at 10 to the seven exams.
So like literally orders of magnitudes.
And our stretch goal for the team is 10 to the eight.
And there's going to be a huge amount of progress in this space within the year.
So this kind of era of
radiomics and artisanal type of research in the space, I think is near
an end the way that it's no longer true within self-driving and other kind of core
AI domains.
That's a bunch of work is happening within the company.
I mentioned the disclosure, and it's not just within scope of predicting many
things that humans can't do, but also a write full report.
So it's like the space is going to get both faster and much broader.
Okay, so that touches on the work of prediction, and I think it's,
to me, super exciting. I've been dreaming of a world in which this space feels as
aggressive and fast, all the parts of AI for kind of forever.
And it's finally time because things are coalescing enough and the technology is
getting more and more unified. Which working on breast is no longer separate from
working on lung or working on pancreas.
It's becoming one unified technical problem.
This causes new problems in translation.
So you've noticed how I told you I care about running trials.
We're running a trial right now in MR,
and yet I have already better models, albeit this is in lung,
and by definition
by the time the trial is done, the model will be totally obsolete because I'll have
a better one. That's kind of a problem, right?
I want better models all the time. I want real evidence of the prospective
utility, and yet every single time I run a trial, by
the time the trial is done, I should have actually much better models already.
And that causes a statistical problem of like, well, what's an evidence framework
to actually encourage people to run trials that's compatible with that pace of
model innovation?
So this
luckily has some statistical solutions I want to share.
So we've been working on a new statistical trial framework called BRIDGE that lets
you kind of recycle models over time.
So you can't do this with all interventions, but let's focus on, well, what does an
AI risk model do?
Does a risk model, say, that PRECI uses or
whoever itself help catch pancreatic cancer early?
No, the actual image does. The intervention you actually assign changes it.
So if you're willing to assume that patients who got the same
recommendation under different risk models, because you can run things in
hindsight, are exchangeable, you can basically do adaptive data
reuse. So I'm going to show you just a quick worked example in the context of our
MIRRO-SDA trial with a preliminary version of MIRRO 1.5 and the
original MIRRO model. So different generations of AI risk model.
Well, for the kind of top 5% high-risk cohort, a bunch of people
overlap, which makes sense, right?
If you have two models that are good, they're trying to catch the same medication.
It's one disease, they should agree on some of the subsets, and I shouldn't have to
re-enroll the same phenotype of people.
So if you do that,
then actually every subsequent trial gets cheaper and faster.
So a natural question is, well, are these kind of overlaps of AI
models over time agreeing with each other common? And the answer is yes.
So I'm showing you three different examples, one in breast cancer, one in
cardiovascular disease, another one in sepsis, with very different kinds of
datasets. This is imaging, ECG, and EMR type
variables. And across different generations of model, if they have
the same type of endpoint, they're trying to understand the same kind of
phenomenon, the overlap is-Very high.
These are all with a top 5% overlap.
But obviously, as the risk definitions change, you have different amounts.
And, well, what does that enable? Well, it not only makes the trial faster, but
fundamentally much cheaper. So once again, I mentioned I'm running these MRI
trials. I pay for the MRIs, very expensive.
The potential saving here is in the millions and therefore valuable.
So if people are interested, I encourage the reference there.
All of that is open with an open demo, et cetera, like click controls,
calculator type of interface.
Okay. So I
probably spoke a little too fast, but as it goes.
That covers a speed run across a bunch of different areas across both
prediction, which really feels like core deep learning innovations, things across
pre-training, post-training, architecture design.
If folks are interested, happy to share more.
Control, I didn't touch much on, but I think there's a really rich space of, as you
have these better tools, how do you imagine much more flexible types of guidelines?
If we end up saying, "Oh, I have a new model to say do this for 20 years," we have
failed. There's something-- We see more information, so we should be able to act
better. And finally, translation, because we should expect better tools to
happen faster than any trial. It's going to require new statistical frameworks.
And now I want to close with kind of what if it all works.
I think the easy case
is cases where we already have a lot of data, like breast and lung and more
broadly, clinical reports in radiology where we have lots of volume.
The hard case where I'm super excited is areas like pancreatic cancer and other
diseases where we just don't have that much data in any one AMC.
And how do we take the innovations and the core model development to open up more
and more domains to be AI-enabled rather than
high-data domains being AI-enabled, everything else is manual feature engineering.
So, and I think it's going to also open new doors on product spectrum.
And with that, I want to say thank you, and happy to take questions.
I'm also blind, so I will try to see.
Over there.
I have a question. So as you develop the models in ADAPT,
are you able to identify the variables that come to the top that are
the most contributing to the performance of the model?
Are you able to curate those, find them, and collect them,
and put them at the top as you go on to the next models?
Or is it agnostic in terms of the variables that
are part of the models?
Yeah, it's fundamentally agnostic.
So, it takes full volumes without any preprocessing and then gives you new
outputs. So if I wanted to understand now what subset of my input
volume helps me explain the model prediction, I can do that.
The thing is, it doesn't necessarily have to be the same explanation for two
different people. So sometimes we're lucky and there's a single
phenomenon, right? Like a small one is called BRCA, and it explains many things.
Sometimes we're not that lucky, and it's actually a bajillion things that all act
somewhat independently that come together towards an explanation.
So just a follow-up question. If you were able to develop a
model where you could identify the high-performing variables,
would that help us sort of go back and forth with the data that
we're collecting to identify-
Yeah
... what's missing or how to make it better, how to make the technology for
radiology better, get that feedback?
Yes. So, that's definitely a thing.
And I'll say that now we're doing that at a level that's much more abstract, right?
So if I have longitudinal imaging, I can say, well, which scan in my
longitudinal sequence made the most difference? Which modality?
Which acquisition parameter? What I'm not getting is which pixel.
Yeah.
That's fine because I would never collect data one pixel at a time because I
can kind of amortize that cost. And so my view is not that we get to a space in
which we give everybody maximal imaging forever.
My opener was like, we sometimes use too much, we sometimes use too little.
We should actually be able to get better net with actually much less total
screening. And that, it comes down to being able to understand where was value
actually driven.
Thank you.
Adam, just to kind of follow up on that.
We're collecting, or not just we in Preceive, but
across many cancers at risk, we're collecting multimodal data,
right? Blood tests, germline testing, imaging.
It could be for each cancer type, there's a different--
Maybe just the imaging is all you need, but it could be that having the
germline test and the imaging may be more important in other cancers than other,
but obviously, we can discern that, right?
Yep.
And maybe just comment on what you've seen with breast, and does your
AI imaging get augmented by having any additional
patient information, or is the imaging alone sufficient versus
lung, for example, and smoking?
Yeah. So I'd say the pattern is clearly different by disease area.
So in breast, we tried combining the imaging model with everything within
Tyrer-Cuzick, which has detailed family history.
Does the person take hormone replacement therapy? How many children?
Last breastfeeding, blah, blah, blah.
And none of that helped. It didn't make any difference over the imaging model
alone. And in some other experiments, we saw that you can actually predict a lot of
these variables from the image. And so, in some sense, specifically in breast,
breast imaging is a phenotype, and many things kind of collide into that.
And so you can understand, did this person breastfeed from the mammogram alone?
So adding it doesn't help.
But that's not always going to be true.
In lung cancer, that's not the phenomenon at all.
If we add other smoking-related factors, not all that's mediated through the lung,
you can't predict it from the lung CT. And so adding it actually helps.
And I think that where I think we'll end up is there's going to be this
natively AI multimodal integration in which you're always saying, "Given what I
know, what should I be acquiring next?" And some tests that might be not good
enough alone as an MCET, if you can train it like this person's high-risk lung
cancer just by this image, you can now make it viable.
Everything's kind of sequential decision-making, and it should be integrated across
everything. Also, I think there's similar lessons that we see within the imaging
world. Like if I take an image, I feed it as radiomics, my upper bound on what's
possible is completely wrong. What you can do with deep learning is not any
different from what you can do off radiomics.
I think we'll see similar things in the way we tackle other problems and other
modalities. Like what you can do with a genome language model that looks at every
base pair and understands stuff like we see with these Evo models is different than
SNPs.
And so every one of these places has room for more richness.
It's going to be a dynamic area for a while to come.
I have two questions. The first is, so in your prediction part
when you showed your model and how it was better on various
tasks and questions, there were many questions that you had in each section.
And so the question is just more generally, how do you decide how to weight those
questions or whether the questions are all equally important in deciding one model
is better and to use experts or just the general concept there of-
Yeah
... that.
So in this context, I didn't weight them at all.
I was trying to be as comprehensive as I could convince my clinical collaborators
to write down.
So what we were looking for was raw dominance.
We wanted coverage across as broad as possible.
Now, that is a proxy indicator. It's not the true thing,
because one thing we're doing now is we're making new types of metrics for report
generation. The two types of tasks that I care about is one of them is to make it
easier to do the current diagnostic flow faster and better and more
accurately,
and that's not the same as to give me the average performance across a dozen
questions because it's long tail, long coverage.
It's actually like a natural language generation problem.
We're working on some new metrics there, and the validation is this a good metric?
Does it correlate to human preference?
If I give you two reports, one of them is better than the other, and you say so,
does the metric produce that behavior consistently?
So we're running reader studies on that phenomenon all the time, and I expect to
publish out that new metric, which we're calling Beam within like...
I'll call Natalia. But like within-- Every day I say, "Is today the day?" And she's
told me that today's only maybe the day, so we'll see. But working on it.
It's a very important question.
Awesome. Thanks. And the other question is, with your
patient reuse
bridge study sort of layout, what is your method to get
traction with that to actually get accepted as a way to run a trial?
Yeah, I think
in a way, we built this because I saw this coming from my own trials.
Yeah.
Because we're running trials, and from the beginning, if we don't have a better
model by the time this is over, we have messed something up fundamental.
So this work is currently under review, and we'll definitely be using this as part
of our core flow because we'll be innovating at such a pace on the model side,
it's not possible any other way.
If others have feedback on how to enable more of the
world's benefit from this, I would love to learn, but I've been
tackling more as like this is a critical path in our own work, and so we're just
going to
dog food it, live through doing.
Cool. Thank you.
Hi, Dr. Ayala. Thank you for the very interesting talk.
Could you speak a bit about the demographic diversity of the data that you're
using to train these models? And in particular for Mirai, you talked about
deploying it in 90 countries across the world.
So did you note any differences in performance across those diverse
demographic groups?
Yes. Thank you for the question. So
once again, this is something kind of depends by the type of model that you're
using, and going bar from the beginning makes your life much easier.
So
we find so far that
X-ray style models, meaning things like Mirai looks at mammography, the CT-based
models, out of the box generalize really, really well.
And so what I mean by that is Mirai was only trained on data from MGH, which is
like 80% white only in Boston. And so it was
not expected that it would work out of the box in CJ MASH in
Taiwan or in Asuta in Israel or
with colleagues in Nigeria. We had to test that along the way, but we
find that it seems to work reliably in all these different testing settings.
You do not get that behavior for free in MR.
And there, the differences are actually the acquisition is so different from place
to place. So it's an individual question by
condition. Does this vary dramatically by subgroup, so you need to train
differently? Now, what we do now for pillar one is we're collecting
very large... We're trying to collect data at a scale that's on the order of like
our surgical for the year is 10 to the 8. You can't get that kind of volume.
You can't get it from any one place.
It has to be national scale and international scale to get those kind of numbers,
which makes generalization much easier.
But for us, we have to test it every single time to know because
it's never guaranteed.
So to that point on having sufficient data, have you considered generating
synthetic X-rays or other kinds of imaging modalities?
Yeah. So we think a lot about synthetic data generation, partially to develop
reasoning traces to improve model capabilities.
I don't think it really helps in address kind of like latent bias in distribution,
because it's easier to interpret the scan than to generate a
scan. And so you get into this chicken and egg consistency problem.
But there is really great work in data engine generation.
I'm happy to chat more about offline. So that's a core research of ours.
It's not for that problem. It's more for how do we expand capabilities
to make new things possible for the model.
Thank you.
Okay. AI for good. Thank you, Adam.
And thanks, everyone, for attending the session.
Hope you found it-